with the surging number of people being
apprehended at our southern border
immigration officials are using get this
planes now to transport some migrants to
facilities in other parts of the country
for processing only on CBS this morning
Omar Villafranca got a look at one of
the first migrant flights operated by
Immigration and Customs Enforcement and
the Border Patrol he joins us from
Dallas
Omar good morning good morning homeland
security officials say border patrol
stations in South Texas are overwhelmed
and overcrowded with migrants and a
majority of the migrants that are
basically coming over the border our
family units that means parents with
children and as these facilities get
overcrowded immigration officials are
now turning towards the sky and we got a
first-hand look this is the next step in
a long journey for around 135 migrants
the men women and children are boarding
a plane in Brownsville Texas when we
arrived at the airport buses were lined
up each packed with more than 40
migrants the facility where they were
originally being held is overcrowded we
blurred everyone's face to protect their
identities and we're starting to see
some family units moms dads and younger
kids from here they're checking their
pockets to see if they have anything in
them then they're loading them onto an
airplane and from there that plane will
take off and take them to a destination
where there will be further process the
migrants don't know where they are going
according to immigration officials
they're headed for a processing facility
in Del Rio Texas these flights operated
by ice for Border Patrol are expected to
become more regular on Friday around 100
migrants were flown from the Rio Grande
Valley to San Diego for processing but
the flights come at a price to the tune
of around twenty to sixty thousand
dollars each or as ice' told us the
equivalent to about nine thousand
dollars an hour the goal is get these
individuals into a safe and secure
environment as quickly as possible
Matthew albuns is the acting director of
ice
he said the flights are the most
efficient way to transport migrants to
less crowded facilities for faster
processing it's being done because the
numbers of the border are so
overwhelming last month
Border Patrol apprehended nearly 99
thousand people that's more than doubled
the amount of apprehensions in April
last year we're seeing a challenge that
we've never seen before and Brian
Hastings is the border patrol law
enforcement operations chief if the
family in it's worn on criminal we begin
releasing them because we simply ran out
of room some of those people are staying
here at this Catholic Charities in the
Rio Grande Valley that's where we met
Alex who is from Guatemala we asked him
why he believes there is an influx of
migrants hungry there there's no jobs
and it's just culminating into a lot of
numbers at the border and as the numbers
continue to increase so made the flights
it's that bad of a crisis with those
high of the numbers now ice told us that
these flights are rare but jets have
been used in the past to transport
migrants and keep in mind there's
roughly 16,000 migrants in border patrol
custody and they're looking at all
options to detain them Gailen you know
we had a story earlier in this broadcast
Omar that five kids have died in US
custody I hope somebody's paying
attention to that because that is not
okay I wonder if you know anything about
that and I'm also curious about what
happens once the migrants are flown to
this new processing facility well once
they get to the new processing pillows
for so
what we understand from Isis that's when
actually the immigration proceeding
starts they're basically asked you know
what are they doing here if they have a
credible fear of returning to their home
country then an interview is set up with
an asylum officer at a later date and
that allows them to stay in the US as
for the deaths of course we have not
heard anything on the a but that
something will absolutely get back to
you with Gail yeah it's very very
upsetting thank you so much